Bonjour, mesdames et messieurs
les passagers leur ont parlé joserra
berasátegui commissaire de vol 25 49
de la compagnie de la péninsule à destination
Américo df s'il vous plaît faites attention
Ensuite, nous allons faire un
démonstration sur les aspects de sécurité
de ce vol note qu'il y a huit
portes de sortie quatre de chaque côté de la
avion
chacun d'eux est marqué du
mot de sortie
sur le bas de leurs sièges
sur l'unique longueur du couloir il y a quelques
lumières qui s'allument en cas de
balisage d'urgence des itinéraires
évacuation toutes les issues du
la violence y compris les fenêtres
au-dessus des chambres ont une rampe
gilets d'évacuation gonflables
gilets de sauvetage sont situés ci-dessous
de chacun de leurs sièges
mais il ne faut pas s'y attendre à moins qu'il ne soit
nécessaire
chaque gilet est réalisé dans un sac
pour extraire le ruban rond tirez
qui dépasse vers l'avant et pour
ouvrir le sac il faut le casser en tirant
fortement qu'avec syndic dans le même
une fois le sac ouvert, il arrivera de
gilet s'étendant